that's the best arse i've seen on the
silver screen
[Laughter]
that's the best sound i've seen on the
silver screen my g
wow
my man's clapping her yeah bro
[Music]
what's good people happy monday fun day
hope you've had a great weekend i hope
you had a good previous week hope you
have a great start to this week where
you obviously are because you listen to
the second best podcast in the world pow
you've got no choice but to feel good
voice but
you know what else me sometimes
when celebrities get carried away in
their own foolishness
i think they are the the voice of some
of the people yeah yeah is it the thing
that you posted the other day about um
taking girls on dates you have to pay or
yeah bet he's done a couple things
that's the only thing i've seen
he did one tweet i think it was a tweet
right yeah it was a tweet which got
posted yeah yeah so one was like oh
um
so yeah one was a thing about like
you're basically you're not a man if if
you're splitting bills or whatever like
if you're taking it yeah
you should pay
and then he re he tweeted again because
people have x about it saying like
oh people who are vex are showing the
real men from the boys
like my mom always said like men make
the money women chop it up i said what i
said whatever and then he tweeted again
the other day that got reposted and was
basically like um oh like something
along the lines of like
i don't care what you think or something
like that you're never ever gonna find
your soulmate on social media whatever
and it's just like i know twitter is a
platform for people to just express
themselves and stuff like that and maybe
it's not his fault maybe he doesn't
think that he is the voice of whatever
maybe he's just tweeting but when these
things get blown up like that and then
like shade is taking it and being like
oh dude you're just like
you get the interpretation who do these
people think they are like
shut up and tweet about your own life
yeah well
it's
it's kind of double-edged because
obviously yes he was just tweeting to
tweet he was just he was just expressing
how he feels
he has no control over like shade bar
and all this a lot retweeting or posting
his stuff which has blown it into this
thing that is now i say blow but you
know what yeah you know so i i get it
and i also feel like he was just
chatting i hope he was he would just
chat you know
unfair fair play this that's what
twitter's for for him to just chat
express your mind and do what you need
to do whereas me or us or whatever i i'm
a retweeter on my personal anyway all i
do is like a retweet that's what i'm
doing yeah i mind my business and just
laugh on the topic yeah i don't use
twitter for [ __ ] that's what i'm doing i
can't be bothered to express my emotions
like that i mean i can't be able to
express my thoughts to verbalize my
thoughts and have people try and chat
back to me i the thing is i only do it
when i'm like super duper gassed about
certain things for example today
well what are you going to say what do
you think of it do you think i'm going
to say science oh maybe not what are you
going to say
i tweeted today is what i'm going to say
yeah what did you tweet i tweeted about
uh demonstration yeah that's what you
were going to say
episode 10. i don't know what episode it
was it was the latest episode whatever
came out yesterday or last week yeah
yeah yeah
episode yes it's episode 10 i watched it
last night
wow
wow
indeed bro
demon slayer is
for those let me actually read my tweet
word for word because
every single time i watch another
episode it gets better and better and
better and it just doesn't make sense
how these writers are doing what they're
doing you know there's only one more to
go don't say that to me brother
yeah there's only one more in this whole
arc yeah this has to be
a part one part two in a season oh it
has to be of course of course but i
think season one was as well wasn't it
see i'm sure someone was a part one i
can't remember it was wild
camera like three years ago maybe two
years three maybe two
not three surely not three i don't
remember bro but yeah oh yeah apparently
there's only one because they said
there's 18 episodes is it 18 episodes
and yes episode 10 was yesterday
um and they they're including
the movie that they then split up into
seven episodes do you remember so if you
go on crunchyroll okay they've got the
movie as a whole yeah but then if you
want to watch it as just as an episode
yeah seven episodes so they're part
they're using that as part of season two
so this so next week's episode is the
finale is what you're saying it's
episode 18
no
apparently so
no
i'm infested but
it makes a lot of sense now because the
finale of last week's episode the way it
ended and the way the credits rolled and
everything wasn't the same i thought
that's what made me look into it because
the way they wrote the credits i was
thinking is this it and they locked the
whole thing
yo what an anime
so for those that were that are invested
or even watched demonstrating if you
don't watch demonstrate you know what
you're doing i tweeted demon slayer
season 2 is giving me that game of
thrones energy where every app was
basically rated 9.9 at imdb
so netsu is also the most underrated
goat of any anime i've seen in a very
very long time that's a statement
is a different caliber of man i'm not
skipping i've not
when that man is easy
he can fight he slept this whole season
he slept this whole season you're right
he's not woken up once and he's just
the first thunderclap flash thing he did
on the underground
yo i could have screamed brother fam a
man went what was it he went god mode or
something last week godspeed god speed
last week god tear or ever
[ __ ] up his legs but he was like [ __ ]
it his legs are pulsated they were
looking wham and they were pulsating yo
his uh his speed is a different caliber
he gasses me more than anyone in that
show and i don't know why because he's
like the third fourth lead
it just doesn't make sense to me but he
gasses me bro yeah but he has to be
gasses
me more than him though really in in
episode 10 yes when he came through at
the end spoiler all right yeah let's
just do a spoiler alert yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah from when
he
popped back in the team yeah
the scrap between the brother and tengen
whilst um tanjiro was trying to get a
squeeze
don't waste time a [ __ ] jump let's do
this sam when tangiero
we thought he was dipping
plotting man was scheming all this while
he shanked his leg a man just went
when he
chopped his thing and the fire went mad
because i thought his flame breathing's
done yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was screaming yo tanjiro zanetsu in
this um in this cave that that trio that
it's a it's a solid trailer it is i've
not been that invested in the trio since
like naruto i've not been invested in
seven team seven yeah i was a new team
bested in them they're the new team
seven wow
wow their own stuff on stuff season two
is
literally a great elevation from season
one oh great elevators come out guns
blaze they're saying
no fillers none of this [ __ ] none of
this arcting story thing we're going
arms for arms for arms for arms for arms
maybe like the first two to three
episodes it was a bit slow but you had
to get the context i liked this i loved
this i loved it because you have to get
the concept when you get in the content
and you're diving into this sun
breathing thing and all of that exactly
you need that and then they sent us to
hell and back bro they've been fighting
since episode four scrapping episode
four these men have been fighting six
episodes straight they've been arms
house
how the writers and the under i i don't
even know bro there's like these graphic
designers are doing all these things
that sir
artistry on that episode was another
level in all of the episodes bro in all
the episodes demon slay is literally top
two right now oh 100 it's literally top
two right now speaking of top two i've
intentionally not watched any attack on
titan
oh i forgot it's back i've watched any
of it got its back so that's obviously
next i forgot that's back but our dc
world tweeted yesterday
saying that um
demon slayer episode 10 and this attack
on titan episode were both 10 out of 10.
really
we're both 10 out i'm watching attack on
time when i get into it
i promise you i'm watching it when i get
into that i promise i forgot because i
saw it release
maybe a few weeks guys probably drops
what what we now we're mid feb probably
and it came up like
late tail end of jan i completely forgot
it came out completely forgot because
i've been looking for something to watch
back to back to back that's why i've
left it week on week or week that's what
i've left you know i want to be
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] i love anime this is so soft anime
bro sorry guys but for the guys i don't
love anime like you obviously know we're
a big fond fan of anime you've got anime
there we've got anime there and it's
just something we talk about week in
week out
banging like
we got messages this morning to talk
about episode 10. oh did we i've never i
saw like four oh guys four different
messages saying please just chat about
this
gang fam
[ __ ]
episode
these man when tanjiro got shanked by my
man in here
and i was like
am i just saying keep going keep
fam
fam lop his [ __ ] head off
now bro i still as much as we're talking
about tanjore as much as we're talking
about tengen as much as we're talking
about that whole fight with um
um the six what's it's team not team six
opposition the upper sixth the the
brother
i still can't get over zenetsu bro yeah
oh he was a different type
throughout not even just that episode
throughout these whole seven to ten
episodes he has produced magic oh he's
gone off he's produced magic my one
qualm was when they wasted an episode
which i understand but it's just like
how he's going off now
is annoying because like
it's obvious he could have he could have
sent for her
from three episodes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they had him in a new skate
playing tattletails yeah yeah
yeah yeah wow some kids chase
they wasted time over here because i was
thinking the whole time because it's
annoying me because i was actually
thinking the whole time when's he gonna
do something because he's just dodging
yeah yeah he's just dodging and these
men are going arms like when's the
unless you're going to kick it in and
then as soon as he gets crumbled
all you heard was
that and you saw the lightning
fam man took a head and said let's go
let's [ __ ] go godspeed godspeed let's
go it's my last opportunity let's go
family he was just losing it and anusca
said fan i got you i got you you man
think it's a game poison what poison
poison do you know who i am
no in this case i love him sometimes
because he's so about the beat yeah he
just wants to scrap that's all he's here
for he wants to find the strongest
person and beat them yes fam that's all
he's there for he's all about this is my
namesake
you men are sleeping on me
week after week after week i'm sending
for you
but do you know one thing we've all
forgotten about episode one obviously it
continues from the movie
where my man's running away the guy that
um tandra threw his sword the upper
three upper three he threw his sword at
upper three and then upper three went
back to the kid the boss and the boss
stared at him
the power
my man has that spiritual pressure
it felt like dragon ball z fam yeah
i couldn't believe what i saw and
they've not shown me again since yeah
he's been out of the since
i cannot wait for that arc oh i cannot
wait for that oh hundred percent [ __ ]
yeah fam 100
we can talk about anyway for fun oh yeah
it's too much for two weeks yeah i was
too much too much too much um but anyway
guys happy monday welcome back welcome
welcome you already know what to do we
want you to pause this episode right now
and head on over to
patreon.com forward slash ships and gigs
and then with that you're going to get
an episode every single thursday um
randomly i got a message on patreon the
other day that said a guy um
basically had a guy sign up the other
day and said oh like i've been wanting
to sign up for ages but i have no idea
what patreon is it just seemed like a
hassle okay and now i've signed up i
realized it was [ __ ] easy yeah so
maybe you should explain to people like
me how easy it is okay cool so i never
even thought that was a thing but okay
if you guys are um
yeah and you're thinking i don't know
what patreon is i don't really want to
be putting my money on some random thing
i don't know how hard it is to set up
it's [ __ ] easy okay so what you need
to do
head on over to patreon.com for shits
and gigs either that or let you go to
the app store download the [ __ ]
patreon app which is super easy
type in shits and gigs pay your three
pound a month tempe a day run the p it's
nice and easy and then that's going to
give you access automatically to every
single episode we've ever done on there
nodes on there all the audios on there
if you like to listen you literally use
it just the way you do spotify you
[ __ ] press play you can close the app
you can turn your phone off do whatever
you want it's still going to play you
can download it to listen to later
and if you like watching it it's
literally exactly the same as youtube so
once you press it it redirects you to
our special hidden playlist on youtube
and you just watch it as you normally
watch it super [ __ ] easy guys so head
on over to patreon.com forwards our
shits and gigs to get yourself an extra
episode every thursday and see all the
catalog stuff that we've ever done and
have yourself a little binge yeah mom um
on top of that guys if you are watching
on youtube please use the two fingers of
death
ring that bell hit the notifications
subscribe of course please like it if
you like it and last but not least
chirps a thing in the comments bag a man
just write chirps literally in the
comments just write chirps chirps chips
church it's celebrating it i love it
back and forth it's hilarious i just see
chubs
so
we're happy to see the chirps chirps in
uh let's keep the chirpzins moving yeah
um so we can get obviously like i said
our breeding grounds we want to get a
nice wooden heart
in the middle of nowhere
white robes
yeezys yeezys
white robes and yeezys and that's where
the colts gonna remember ma'am
speaking of go on yeezy's going through
it this week this couple past couple
weeks a man's been tweeting and man's
been
posting he's livid he's he's sick and
tired he's living yeah you're sick and
tired wow it just goes to show money
doesn't solve everything money really
doesn't solve everything when it comes
to family situations obviously he's
going through a hard time he's going
through a divorce i don't know if
they're actually officially divorced yet
he's seen another woman he's trying to
balance you takes butters as well
she's a niche pet she
i'm glad you came to an agreement
without me speaking yeah she's because
in uncut gems
this [ __ ] is that the yacht from yes
brother i didn't even realize exactly is
he able to cheat exactly okay oh wow
exactly okay exactly i need to take her
back all i saw was a quick pick i'm
sorry
she looked like a married man
yeah i know that's the chick from
cheeks
oh sailor cheeks were jiggly
i take that back into i had no idea
what's happening it's her brother i had
no idea it was her
but no idea was her
problem her cheeks
that's the best arse i've seen on the
silver screen
[Laughter]
that's the best art i've seen on the
silver screen my g
wow
my man's clapping her yeah bro
please
i take it all back bro
yeah she lives in new york i believe
because he always flies to new york to
go to pattana i'd fly to new york to
partner as well bro
she looks so different now though yeah
she does so different now well then
again obviously she was obviously acting
in that movie to play that role but yeah
she doesn't look like the same person
like you said you didn't even know it
was her it's her mad it's her bro
i can't remember her name you i can't
remember her name he's he's going
through it man he's going for it bro and
he always types in caps lock
he's just screaming every time
every time you just type it in capslot
stop tweeting no man
just deal with it it's just it's yeah
you know that's who he is get in the get
in the lawyer's office and handle this i
don't want to see it on twitter yes yeah
bro that is yeah it's always been
exactly it's always been yay and i feel
like
it's one of those ones where
he's obviously
been in a position where he's never had
well i'm speculating so don't obviously
take my word for gospel
but he's been in a position where he's
obviously lost his mum at a young age
right he never really knew his dad
and
he's had to find his way through life in
this whole he got so famous so quick
he's been in the industry 15 17 years or
whatever he's had to find his feet and
he's had to deal with all of this
pressure with no form of guidance yeah
he's gone through
um the graduation phase to wearing the
remember the glasses that had like slits
here stronger guys the 808 and
heartbreak phase yeah for all of that
then he went through the years as
christian phase then he stopped doing
music for a bit then he was with kim
then he started doing the christian go
to church phase like he's gone through
so much and now he's getting a divorce
bro
like
when you sit when you take a step back
and actually look at his career and look
at his life
when you see it in like
day-to-day life obviously you sit there
and think this [ __ ] is crazy
this [ __ ] is crazy when you
actually look at it for
face value then in there but when you
actually take a step back and digest it
as a whole yeah you're like raw boy
people go for [ __ ] regardless of status
regardless of who you are in this world
regardless of who you've gotten pregnant
regardless who your kids are whatever
bro he's going through something you
talking for a know he's tough man i
wouldn't want to be in this position i
would never want to be in his position
because he is an advocate of freedom of
speech he says what the [ __ ] he wants
man was going for a maga hat phase for
[ __ ] sake
do you know what i mean
he is [ __ ] for [ __ ] he's he he is an
advocate of freedom of speech
clearly he is he is easy as he is
because he has no one to but not
necessarily no one to bounce think off
bounce things off of
but
he even kind of quite a period of time
lost his best friend jay-z yeah you know
yeah there are certain things in life
daisy said
i just
jesus i just yeah i just can't say
i'm gonna slap you
i just
can't with you i can't like i'm
i'm 67 years old you know what i mean
like i can't
do this anymore
dragging me into this
and i just i just want to chill bro
i just made it
that's so funny to me bro
so funny to me but yeah he's gone
through so many different phases yeah so
many different phases it's easy to
blame it on this or blame it on that or
but when you take like i said when you
take a step back and look at his life as
a whole and the different stages this
guy has gone through
clearly he's not been in the best
positions to deal with certain
situations but he's at the end of the
day he's he's still a human being he's
allowed to
have freedom of expressing himself he's
allowed to have an opinion on what his
kids do do do and don't do that whole
tick tock thing i understand you know oh
100 i understand
yeah the laws are and the rules are as
he posted you have to be 13 minimum to
have a tick tock you know there are
certain things where kanye's [ __ ]
right of course fam it's just top yeah
it's tough that he
it's tough that he has to resort to
exposing her quote-unquote bad parenting
in order to get his own way yeah do you
know what i mean
it's sad that he has to take to
instagram
to get his daughter off tick-tock yeah
because ain't no one here in here in the
yard bro the one sorry to cut you off
brother the one that [ __ ] vexed me
was um
one of the kardashians cousins i've seen
like the the text messages do you follow
us absolutely nothing you don't follow
kanye i follow you on on instagram and
he's not a screenshot all i see is was
reposted okay he screenshotted some
conversations that he had with one of
the kardashians cousins coincidentally
one of their names began with kf who was
things like candice or something
um she was going back and forth about
the
the daughter situation about personal
tick tock blah blah
next paragraph was
am i comfortable buying yeezys because
of the stock market blah blah blah and
man replied don't talk to me about
yeezys right now like how dare she even
bring that up in this topic of
conversation so that's adding fuel to
his fire you know what i mean so when he
reacts he's now painted as the bad guy
yeah yeah because he's losing his
[ __ ] mind brother i'm trying to save
my kids
couple adidas
shut up
do you know what i mean
do you know what i mean
he's getting pain that's such a bad guy
whether he's right whether he's wrong i
don't understand i don't know i don't i
don't necessarily care that much but he
seems like a care right now because i
can understand his position
i can understand his position
cause galley loves to put mandam in
corners sometimes do you know what i
mean
they do they're galley love to put madam
in corners i'm not for it cuz
i'll fight my way out of the corner
and then pay me us whatever you want
it's just not fair
it's not fair it's true it's true it's
true it's true it's true it's just not
on fam it's [ __ ] not ah
but yeah man um
who i feel sorry for as well who pete
davidson
he's stuck
someone tweet i've got i've got a i've
got an actual tweet that said
i have to find it i don't want to i
don't want to paraphrase but keep going
and i'll find you sorry because kanye's
sending for him oh yeah any chance he
gets
and pete is in a position now because
can't you send it for him
but he's also going for a midlife crisis
oh god he's been been going he lives as
a comedian so i'm sure in his heart he's
thinking let me clap back yeah yeah
cause i've got jokes
yeah yeah but it's
like kim's like you can't though because
you're just gonna look like a prick yeah
like you can't he's clearly going
through [ __ ]
you can't get on stage and start
chucking it to man because you're going
to look like you need like you're you're
[ __ ] his wife and then you're sending
for him you're going to like an [ __ ]
he can send you all he wants yeah
because he don't live here yeah you're
in the yard all the time yeah yeah yeah
and you're around he's using all these
things like it's [ __ ] for you yeah
it's [ __ ] for you basically
and he's doing he's really thinking what
if i got myself into it exactly i just
want to say [ __ ] a kardashian [ __ ]
dick [ __ ] dick
i just want to [ __ ] a kardashian next
thing you know we're on ferris wheels
next week you know there's there's
paparazzi does that and we're together
then next thing you know i just want to
click clap keep clapping the cheeks and
and live a lavish life and now look
where i am i've got kanye west sending
for me with tracks with the game uh
what's the ape shield is it called ape
[ __ ] i don't know why it's the one where
they're like the skinned monkey yeah
rspcco oh that then peter man they yeah
dm asap take that off yeah yeah they
dm'd him asa i hate yeah yeah yeah they
i forgot about that that's long i forgot
about i found the tweet
the thing i didn't skin the tang
the thing was skinned
i didn't take the picture and i didn't
get it actually it's just the album yeah
it's not me it's them the thing's done
um but yeah bro p davidson's going
through it as well but the tweet said
sorry to cut you off it's just a one one
sentence team pete davison's wild for
dating a single mother of four
fam the way i forget how many useless
woman's i'm for you he is wild can you
imagine dating a single mother before
right if it's comedian yes
if it's a kardashian yes i can imagine
date in a single moment i don't give a
[ __ ] it could be a single mother of ten
if it's a kardashian yes i can imagine
doing it the stress though bro yeah but
i would never get in this position i'm
[ __ ] her and i'm leaving yeah but
then you're not dating her okay you're
[ __ ] leaving you as you just said
true he's dating her but
their yard is massive he he's probably
in and he probably don't even see you
yeah yeah
every you has their own nanny like
they've got their own schedule yeah
people don't see you in the house
but
it's different yeah yeah yeah yeah she's
living in a two-bedroom yeah it's very
hard
stop chaos
pancake mix everywhere stop
i don't care how good the tomtom is
i'm not dating you
this is stress for me yeah but pete
davidson is a kardashian he probably
don't see them using them
yeah
um random
have you seen you probably haven't but
on amazon prime um kanye's latest or
most recent uh tour he did
last december
not torture he did a show
in california in um
in a coliseum with drake uh it's on it's
on prime it's actually really good have
you seen it i haven't seen it but you've
seen i've seen it how they did it yeah
but i haven't seen it
i i watched it i think i watched it last
week
it's one of those ones where
you forget how great kanye is because
kanye he it didn't do like his latest
album or his latest couple hits he went
from start to finish and did banger of
the banger of the banger of the banger
of family you forget the tracks this
guy's done sometimes
family when touch the sky came on the
crowd went nuts when that little beat
came in
wrong
okay fair play bro
it went off he forgot a lot of words in
throughout the whole time he forgot a
lot of words throughout the whole team
and fair play to him man's got an a
catalogue of music
no a song i heard recently i don't know
how i heard it but i heard it and i
thought [ __ ] the hell forgot the song
um champion do you remember do you
realize
that you are a champion
[Music]
uh i think it's graduation probably if
it's not graduation it's the one after
late registration i can't remember the
one college dropout college dropper uh
that's the first one actually college
dropout ledger registration oh yeah
sorry sorry um you're right
what's it called again champion yeah
i think it's actually
graduation because that's one of my
favorite albums is graduation that's one
of my favorite albums connie albums
banger i heard a
banger
don't tell me nothing
lalala wait till i get my money right
i had a dream i could buy my way to
heaven when i woke up spent it on a
necklace fam
the whole show was insane fair play i'll
look at it amazon prime you say amazon
prime all right i'll check it out
i'm gonna struggle to watch him miss
words though yeah it's annoying it's
annoying because
there was i think in touch the sky i was
like reciting i was doing back to back
reciting the words and uh he made a
mistake and i was thinking have i made
the mistake you know yeah i'm thinking
oh [ __ ] yeah but oh no it was it was
great man it was i'm sorry i cut you off
yeah
i'm enjoying this episode yeah i'm gonna
have another sip tip
anymore but i'm enjoying myself today
we're just talking bro this is yeah
conversing
here come on come back let me let me let
me let these my name hear me
it's been a while
no no no i'll say when i'm talking just
now not doing this i thought yeah let
them hear me sip my liquid because the
thing was here what i was talking about
i will say let's say that simply sip
sippity sip
[Music]
um
so guys
as you can see i did find a new papa
oh yeah i forgot
i did find you brother thank you so much
for all of the um
the recommendations recommendations
all the recommendations um some of them
look buff there's a thing as well
don't cut yourself out the car
it's
expensive the guy that hooked me up
today bonnie's charging different prices
he he he saw who he was yeah yeah he
thought he thought man can bump up that
vlt because i booked the appointment on
instagram yeah so you did his due
diligence yeah yeah homeboy's got a bit
of
a leverage yeah yeah yeah try to charge
me extortionate prices so
um i'm still in the market but i'm happy
with what i've received today the trip
german's buff i'm not gonna lie to you
buff thank you
i'm not gonna lie to you
thank you bro the fade's tight someone
messaged me saying that fade looks like
a filter
that's how you know you've won that's
how you know that that phone looks like
a filter i said why would i feel to my
[ __ ] fade back how would you even
feel to your fade exactly how does one
do such
um
but yeah thank you so much guys one guy
messaged me and and uh sent me the thing
because obviously i was saying if it's a
girl i want to be banging
a man said satin along the lines of
um
she doesn't cut hair but as a yacht neda
does braids and between me and you i
heard she's on birth control
i didn't know what to reply
he just had to let you know i think i
said in that
that is hilarious that is hilarious you
know what i've said this
so yeah
all good um
but yeah keep the recommendations coming
because when you send me the instagrams
i do my research
i have a look look
you have to i don't want man that i
heavy handed on the spray spray
because that can that can make it look
way better than it actually is of course
of course um but the guy i went to today
was [ __ ] buff so until i see a worthy
opponent i'm gonna stick with my man
because it was not busy in there i had
an appointment anyway but it was not
busy in it wanted to want the birth
control yeah that's a that barbara's
base central thing okay like it looked
busy on the instagram it was busy in
there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway but thank you guys so much for
getting in touch um very much
appreciated
um and i have a little
sharp left sharp left turn
and i found something uh actually this
one i have to give props i can't
remember who sent it so i'm sorry but
someone sent me this the other day and
uh
[ __ ] me is it hilarious gang [ __ ] me is
it hilarious um
let me find it so it was a twitter
thread
so similar to what we did on patreon the
other day with the our worst first dates
or what's the worst thing women did on
first dates
this one is men uh men on twitter share
their first terrible dating experiences
with women
share their first terrible date
experience with women yeah yeah so
terrible day experience on the first
date with women okay
so
i'm laughing already bro um
let me run through some of these because
it some of them sweeted me
right so
the worst thing a woman's done on the
first date
i said bro we were sitting down at the
restaurant and i had to use the bathroom
she put her leg out and tripped me
[Laughter]
first today first date i went to go
toilet she put a leg out and tripped me
that's a bullying that's bullying that
yo
yo bully you are a bully you are a bully
and we need to address this after i
finish it
you want to come back because
i know from that when we get back to
yard you're choking
me you're pinning me to the wall you're
pinning me up and lifting me
biting my bottom lip
stop it stop it
that could never happen
that could never happen nah bro that's
everything said in that little prank
that's hilarious that's all i needed
tonight that's hilarious oh
um
this one
um at a restaurant this girl pinches me
hard as [ __ ] i'm talking like five six
times like to the point i almost hit her
next day my arms will cut up from the
pinches
so i text her to tell her and she goes
that's what you get for being light
skinned
[Laughter]
firm that's not on
that's not on that's unacceptable that
resonated with me
can you obviously imagine resonated with
me
that was my whole uni experience it was
i don't understand why they hated you so
much just because you were light-skinned
it
you didn't do a bad thing to anyone fam
you didn't do anything to anyone i
literally
for the bottom my heart was minding my
own body literally mind your business
persona hated you
she hated my guts bro literally because
of the color of my skin that's racism
that's the definition of racism she
hated me because of the color of my skin
yo she hated it she would say everyone's
name and call you the lighty for no
all of them would the guys were cool the
girls from all of them
who had what's up jacob what's up aaron
ah
yeah
like lighty lighty not even what's up
lady just lady
bisola
that's where our interactions went
for four years bro
[Laughter]
so annoying you got the brunt of every
joke i don't understand why neither do i
oh neither do i man it was so unfair it
was so unfair it was
it's you know what's jokes is what sorry
about that's right i love how you said
so unfair now you were not in my corner
to protect me no one protected me then i
was just about to say it was so unfair
but i was so happy i wasn't
light-skinned you know
because it was weird because obviously
back in um secondary school i think
we've spoken about this in the past like
before we even have a st we had a studio
back in primary school it wasn't cool
being african
high school every tom dick and harry if
you're not jamaican oh you could be
african you couldn't be african you
weren't a la i hadn't
i didn't know i'd met an african until i
was like 16 until they exposed
themselves yeah yeah yeah because you
weren't allowed
it's crazy to think about now crazy fam
you weren't allowed to be african you
could never come to my secondary school
with confidence as i am nigerian bro you
would get roasted from sunrise to sunset
and your mum speaks to you in europa yo
oh you'd have to change schools oh you'd
have to change postcodes you'd have to
you'd have to you couldn't be african in
my school you had you wouldn't get away
with it
it's crazy to think about it's matter if
you're not from the caribbean fam
you're
it was so bad it was so bad thinking
back of it it was so bad bro oh it was
nuts that's why i was like back then i
was happy i wasn't like oh fam it was
nuts in secondary school being light
skinned was the best thing you could be
oh everyone wanted to be a lady
in secondary school bro being
light-skinned from our okay secondary
school for our age group yeah
it's very different now my creed are
suffering in there now
every man's out here listening to nsg
yeah
my amanda's suffering in there now that
said nsg
but back in my day yeah
oh being light skinned was the dream it
was bro you skated through life
everything was just handed to you oh it
was 100
it's crazy because you're so much like
you get more attention
from girls
like girls who like black guys will [ __ ]
you yeah and guys girls who like white
guys will [ __ ] you yep
you were the best of both for any given
situation at any given time oh fam you
were a day walker basically because like
you were bled like blade has all the
gifts of a vampire yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
first i was given every gift yeah and i
had to deal with none of them yeah yeah
yeah no repercussions
apart from hardcore racists yeah of
course i didn't have to deal with it
that was rare it was right it was rare
back in our secondary school days that
was rare i got it more in primary school
than i got in secondary school
um really really hmm okay
i don't um because i told you about
crystal who wouldn't go at me because i
was black
maybe i don't remember when i was a kid
kid i don't remember she said i don't
date black black guys oh really oh my
dad doesn't let me date black guys i
remember he was like eight years old yep
yep yep yep you were at some house party
team yeah so yeah i got peeled off yeah
yeah
yeah what's this anyway oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah light skinned we
skated through life yeah we had all the
gifts yeah
or the the the speed track and field
we were given that
football giving that basketball given
that was having whatever whatever
and yeah yeah we didn't have to deal
with any of the any of the jar i didn't
have to worry about being from africa
bro you never had i didn't cross my mind
come you need time oh come muni times it
flipped
i feel like circa 2008 to 2012
africans united oh they did we you know
as soon as afrobeats became a craze
oh you men were done i'd never felt like
such an exile in my life you man were
done it if you could see the experience
through my eyes i didn't know what was
going on
because
i'd met you but i hadn't really spent
any time with you yeah then i'd
obviously gone to boxing been training
the boxers yeah yeah yeah away from you
guys yeah i'd met [ __ ]
damager
a boxing damn show
for the life of me i don't know his real
name oh no the life of me his name is
michael is it my kid michael is that
he's my damage i remember the boxing
coach called him michael and i was like
michael i swear to god
damn it
anyway man had a shotgun nose i remember
oh fab yeah anyway sawn off
literally um so
he invited me back to his apartment
to chill in that and i was like alright
cool man went there fam
bare people in the in the yard and i was
like i'll swear like
does everyone live here and i'm like no
no no no no no no was it trinity
was it callus it wasn't callis no it was
kallus
i think it was colors anyway i think it
was colors but anyway yeah we went in
there
bare people up in the air they're
africans all up in the air cooking this
that that and i was thinking the [ __ ] is
going on here yeah who lives here yeah
and it was like her like just one girl
the front there's like 15 people in the
yard she lives here and i was like but
everyone's always here like we're all
big one family i was thinking the [ __ ]
yeah and then i met you
oh so you would this happened before you
met me no i'm sorry i had met you but we
hadn't spent any time
you uh asked me if i want to watch the
manu game
in palace i remember
and then we went back to what was your
place called again
did you stay there in first year priory
prior to prison yeah yeah priory prison
yeah we're there and we went to the
basement team yeah all of your man was
there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
all there
was thinking i had cardigans
oh fam same and i was thinking what the
[ __ ] is going on brother
how did these men all know each other
and you're like oh
you're just here like you're 90s around
for seven years scan on bruh
and then we went to the first rave yeah
and i was just on the sidelines fam
these early things
yeah
run these early things
you had to get your practice in before
the dance i was in the full length
mirror
just it's wrist and ankle
there's onto them
so i had to get a lot yeah and i had to
participate even though i hated the
whole experience you hated afrobeats oh
i hated it i've never seen someone you
and rem hated africa oh i did i did
because but as a grown man because i
hated it because i was jealous of it
okay because it was part of your man's
every day yeah yeah and i was actually
just
trying to find your feet
you didn't invite me
i had to have a tantrum before you
invited me
so
yeah bro i was pissed off yeah i hated
the whole that was like the first year
and a half of uni [ __ ] i hated the whole
thing
i was like i don't belong to the white
man yeah because they're racist yeah
yeah i don't belong to the black man
because they're all african yeah and
then the girls just call me lighty and
they don't even bother to know my name
yeah like where do i fit first year of
uniform i literally didn't know where i
felt yeah it makes sense obviously
because you said you were you were going
home week and you were going him week in
week out oh week in week out yeah 100
because it's the only place i fit in we
you were going home
i was like bro just stay for one weekend
let's go out you would never no i was
thinking no friday free p.m
oh 100 fam you will go out what
go out for what for the same thing that
we've been going out for this is on
toting and no one invites me into the
into the circle a man city with a
full-length mirror
yo you went through it first first year
it was dread
then when we started to go into the
multicultural race yeah yeah yeah your
boy came flourished yeah you might came
back
i've never seen such a growth spurt in
my life i've never seen anything like it
the way you flew through uni
oh that second third year wow
i hit my stride wow yeah yeah yeah i was
happy you were in your prime mind i was
happy bro wow i couldn't believe it yeah
man yeah
it was a good turnaround for those that
knew knew
that's what i had to say i couldn't
believe it i was jesus christ
but yeah anyway still going on this
thing yeah
um
right met a girl off tinder yeah we text
for about two weeks and finally decide
to meet up
i go to pick her up and find out she
only has one arm she never disclosed
this
that's not funny bro but
it is have you seen speaking of have you
seen that um
i know the bartender yeah the rock paper
scissors with the free man
and she just pulls at her
yo
i would love her to try that with me yo
i
the thing is i obviously didn't i was
thinking how is she going to beat three
men in rock paper scissors i think she
doesn't make confidence she's coming out
with confidence and she came up with the
this this i don't even know what it was
but snubbing i was like wow
fair play and the mime was like i want
to shake your actual hand it was like
fair play bro fair play bro and she once
she got them the drinks and it was good
it was yeah it was a laugh i'm not
buying a drink
i'm not buying a drink all you man can
buy a drink i'll say you're a [ __ ]
cheater tell me what you picked
she didn't do anything
tell me what you picked because i picked
rock
what did you pick because it wasn't
paper roll scissors
it was the next thing was it was more of
an aloha i rated her confidence yeah
yeah yeah all right 100 um right next
one yeah oh god hit me while driving us
to dinner yeah my phone went off in my
pocket
i look at the text and it's from my date
sent to me accidentally saying oh my god
he's so ugly ah
fight me
fight me bro
fight me
it's food number four all over again
fight me
fight me no that's that's fam i hope i
hope for his sake his boy's sake his
family's surname's sake he got up and
left oh he says at the end yeah she says
it says i pulled over to the gas station
handed her two dollars to run in and get
me some lorry ticks and i drove the [ __ ]
off gang
gang well played
painful well played it is [ __ ]
painful because i know he went home and
looked at himself in the mirror that day
oh he cried
imagine going on a date
and then the date texts you by us and
saying oh my god he's so ugly
that would ruin me i'm not even gonna
lie to anyone on youtube right now but
that would ruin me oh 100
oh my god he's so ugly
i don't think you men know the power of
the words you manhattan 100 bro 100
that would ruin me yeah it would [ __ ] me
up because i would never i would never
say that to a woman of course not and i
would never put myself in a situation
where i'm going on a date with a woman
that i think is that ugly you know what
i mean of course i know what you mean
[ __ ] it's not on that would ruin my week
it's not on bro
um [ __ ] that's hilarious but it's just
it's not it's funny but it's not oh of
course it's not
she showed up to the date five months
pregnant
safe
safe you know who you are as well you
know who you are as well i'll be fuming
oh my days bro five months pregnant the
audacity of it
inviting me to the crib knowing she
ain't paid her electric bill
smashed in the freezing cold
do you know why that statement is so
double-pronged gone he already as as
you're walking into the yard you already
know she's not paid the elections oh
she's flicking lights on and off
nothing's working you open the fridge
getting a drink the light doesn't go
away but yet man still had the composure
to get harder than the [ __ ] yeah of
course he's an animal yeah because men
are animals men are animals she had to
have been she had to have had the goods
the goods apparently fam but i don't
know um
last one
walk my date to our car after a two hour
dinner
wait sorry walk my date to a car after a
two-hour dinner only to find out she
left her kid in the car the whole time
no that's not even funny that's not even
funny that's not even funny i don't
respect that i don't respect that
whatsoever that's not even funny
left back in the car for two hours
so she could go on a date that's not
even funny oh
bad money man no no
if i'm the dad
if i'm just we could run out if i'm the
dad now i could never find that i cannot
be in custody i can never find that out
james
that's not even funny
it's not funny
nah
sometimes
sometimes people take things too far
they do fam too far
[ __ ]
oh jesus christ we've spoken today
we've spoken today where are we at what
are we up to what's next um
just let's finish off yeah you said you
had a special fan request right yeah
quick quick and easy right lads advice
time please
my boyfriend is coming out of prison in
12 weeks we obviously haven't had sex
since we went in a year ago
so the night he comes out obviously it
needs to be very sexy so i need help do
i go down the sloppy top route question
mark my concern here is that it will be
too much if you haven't had sex if you
haven't if you hadn't had any form of
sex in a year would that kill the night
because you you would not straight away
then i'm not going to get mine or do i
go down the romantic route with the
proper love making sex help me out what
do you think absolutely love the pod has
me howling
cool this one for me i've spoke about
before
back a day okay in there there needs to
be
four playhead 100
you have spoken about this before your
needs to be four playhead yeah you can't
just go in guns blazing yeah because he
will not he will
not if it's been a year or not he's gone
enough yeah and don't also don't be so
sure he hasn't had sex a year that's
what i was thinking because she's naive
to think that he's not been
he's not been coerced yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know yeah he's not been
co-wasted
those nights are lonely yeah yeah yo
cheeks or cheeks after a while
cheeks or cheeks
throat is a throat yo um but every night
of yeah yeah yeah all over again watch
the night off and tell me yeah you've
got 12 weeks watch the night off and
tell me that he hasn't had 16 years
um
but i would say just play it by ear man
like man work the same way that women
work
like in terms of like it's a rhythm
thing if you're giving them the slop
slop and you're going going for it of
course it's gonna nut of course but if
you're using it in a foreplay thing yeah
you're going for it you stop you're
going for it you stop we're talking
balls we're talking shaft we're talking
spit we're talking everything yeah so
it's not all heightened it's not all
it's not rhythm like build up build up
build up it's just mad slot but like no
real
yeah tempo yes i know what you mean it's
the tempo that's going to knock him out
yeah um
so for me yeah take the tempo out of the
situation
keep it all for play then i get my
sloppy top you'll get yours and jobs are
good job isn't good that's my advice um
i
i personally think she's just deep in it
way too much i don't necessarily think
she needs to think about should i go
down the sloppy top route or the love
making route i just genuinely think she
just needs to see him embrace him and
just take her from there yeah there's no
way you can plan how to have sex
you've never seen you've not seen in a
year or two however the longevity is
just [ __ ] embrace him see you don't
know what he wants to do
he's not he's not had sex with a woman
let's say for a year
he might want to bang the [ __ ] out of
you in five minutes yeah yeah yeah so
don't worry about it let him let him get
that frustration out first yeah and he
will talk about it tomorrow yeah
that's that's that's what i mean if
you're planning things it's dead it's
different
yeah let's just black out and see what
happens blackout close all the cones
close all the doors lock yourself away
from the world and let's just keep
[ __ ] until we can't [ __ ] anymore okay
and then we go from there all right yeah
yeah
all right guys thank you so much
as always love love love gang gang gang
that was a fun one
[Music]
you